modern feminism for me is very different  from the way feminism was intended to be  you know so i'm somebody that yes you  know people who were initially  advocating for women's suffrage and who  were advocating for  women to have equal opportunity in  education abortion  well i'm i'm pro-life so you know from  my perspective that's a problem in many  respects um  and i feel like it's been glorified and  it's been like oh you know you can just  sleep around and i see all the videos on  tick tock now everyone's like oh if you  you know make it harder for people to  get abortion i'm gonna not be able to  you know sleep around so guys who want  us to sleep around you should be against  this too and i'm like wow this is  societal decay